the last day of their tour and the Duke
and Duchess were back in front of the
press
Prince Harry believes his waging a
campaign against his wife their visit to
a Township to talk about youth
unemployment overshadowed by his
statement he didn't talk about it
publicly but did say he'd always fight
for what's right to have a position that
gives us amazing opportunities and we
will do everything that we can to play
our part in building a better world
behind the smiles this is a man who is
desperate to protect Megan from what he
calls relentless propaganda the timing
of this statement is extraordinary when
you think they've had such a successful
tour and many saw this is not tunity for
them to turn things around after what
has been a difficult summer of headlines
this isn't Prince Harry just taking on
the mail on Sunday he is going into
battle with a whole section of the UK
press
the legal claim against the men on
Sunday has been a long time coming after
they published one of Megan's letters to
her father back in February the papers
were put in this week on legal advice
and it does seem like a peculiar move
and one that took attention away from
the important diplomatic work expected
of them like meeting south africa's
president we understand the Queen and
Prince Charles had been told about it
excuse me can I ask you what your
thoughts had and Prince Harry statements
but don't know if they agreed with
Harry's decision to publish his attack
on the press to was unprecedented I'd
say in terms of the actual scale of the
of the vitriol and the personalization
of it
one can understand him wanting to defend
his wife but you know but I think at the
same time you have to strike a balance
the timing was surprising after they've
appeared so happy and relaxed when they
were meeting Nelson Mandela's Widow
grasa Michelle we spoke to his
granddaughter in Dilla command Ella who
knows all about the complexities of
being part of a world-famous family and
a credibility because of where you come
from but the flip side of that is that
it overshadows you all your life setting
up a battle with the newspapers may not
have been the wisest way to end this
tour even if they do feel under attack
Rihanna Mills Sky News in Johannesburg
[Applause]